what did you see from brady up close
that would give buccaneers fans and
patriots fans some insight as to whether
or not he's still going to be the guy
that he was
look i saw him on august 14th i saw him
for two days but i one of the days was
august 14th and as i wrote
he looks great on august 14th
the issue is how's he going to look on
december 14th
so
i you know look
i saw him throw
ropes uh not like that pass to
gronkowski or this one really to uh
whoever oh you know who that is you know
that that's antoine randall that's
amazing he's an assistant coach now is
that amazing you know i i because i
asked one he looked like a receiver and
i asked one of the pr guys i think oh
that's antoine randall he had the little
bucket hat on but
what here's here's the thing i think
about brady okay
he is having so much fun
he is loving it so much if you saw the
little interview i did with him
you know uh on stream yard the the video
conference interview i did look look at
look at him smiling i can tell you on
january 4th
when he lost to the tennessee titans it
was his last game ever in foxborough i
can tell you i spent 10 minutes with him
after that game in a private room he was
not smiling that night
and
and and he is just happy you know you
guys probably played or heard this that
he told me this is the first time in 30
years
that i have been uh coached my head
coach has been an offensive coach
and that's amazing i actually went back
and checked it yes his high school coach
for four years in california at sarah
high was defensive coach lloyd carr
including the redshirt year five years
at michigan yeah defensive coach and of
course belichick 20 years defensive
coach so now
one year his first year out of 30 he's
got aryans and
the sign that this is going to be
i think a pretty cool relationship is
that
a bruce aryans is letting tom brady
coach the receivers
and and you know
guy you know their assistant coaches are
not chafing at this from what i could
tell he's going out there and talking to
them and to oj howard about what he
would really like them to do and that
has been really eye-opening for aryans
and number two
aryans a couple of weeks ago had a
three-hour meeting with brady and he
just said hey i just want to know what
you like
let's talk about plays yeah it's not
it's not okay let's talk about your
philosophy what do you want to do do you
like going more no huddle do you like
going shotgun what it's plays
show me plays that you like
and so
look i don't know if they're going to
win i don't know how healthy brady is
going to be all year i can tell you
brady has heard everyone
who is said
that he won't last or this is not going
to work or a 43 year old quarterback has
never done this he is taking great
delight
in that i can tell you and
uh
so we'll see but he sure looked good the
two days i saw him and uh i i i think
the news is going to be good in tampa
one or two things just to hit on you
know before we move into the next team
in tampa one i just want you to give me
a
you know an estimate whether it's
through bruce arians or brady about
how far along we are in the offense
where's the comfort level with brady and
you know erasing the england you know
new england terminology and the tampa
bay and also just before we move on you
got to hit gronk and just where he's
fitting in with the tampa bay tight end
play and everything right now peter
yeah i think you know aryans
has spoken about brady being comfortable
with about 90
of their offense and this was a week or
so ago
um
brady brady will be comfortable with the
offense
i don't think that's going to be an
issue because he understands how much he
has to do now you ask about gronk i
think this tight end position is going
to be absolutely fascinating i would
look for o.j howard if we're talking
about number of snaps
oj howard more than cameron great
cameron wright more than gronk okay
that's just my guess
i think gronk
you know be careful of of of of thinking
that gronk is gonna play 800 snaps 13
touchdowns and you know
whatever 80 catches that's not going to
happen i think you're going to see grunk
play
in
the you know almost all red zone
opportunities
and i think
i would just guess just be a guest of
mine that he'd play three to four
hundred snaps and maybe down the stretch
if they're in playoff contention they
really need a i mean who knows maybe he
has a 55 snap game but i think the way
aryans looks at this right now and the
way jason like gm looks at it brady oj
howard great marriage and they're gonna
try to make that marriage work as a
regular tight end
and peter i think you're on to something
here because look at what happened in
2018 rob gronkowski was not used as
extensively during the regular season we
kind of just assumed hey he's not the
guy he used to be and then pow in the
playoffs it's the old gronk making big
catches against the chiefs to get to the
super bowl making the key catch against
the rams in that super bowl win and i
think that it would be smart especially
since he sat out for a whole year and
he's healthy keep him healthy keep them
fresh keep them ready for the games that
are really going to count and i think
the bucks are going to be in the games
that really count when december and
january rolls around
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports